Vamos a resolver un par de preguntas para ver si
realmente entendemos esto bien, así que primero
vamos a tomar 79. Pausa el video, resuelve esto
por tu cuenta y veamos qué respuesta obtienes y
cómo fue que lo resolviste para revisar si los
dos estamos pensando de manera similar. Así que
cuando miro 79, en mi mente veo que 79 es mayor
que 1, mayor que 5, mayor que 10, mayor que 50,
pero no es mayor que 100, así que definitivamente
necesitaré un 50 para escribir este número en el
sistema romano. Escribo una L, y ahora sé que el
79 se representa como 50 + 29, y puedo olvidarme
de este 50 por la L que ya escribí. Ahora necesito
representar este 29, entonces ¿qué puedo hacer?
Puedo olvidar que empecé con 79 y pensar que todo
lo que tengo que reescribir es 29 y lo que obtenga
se lo añado a esto, así que considero 29 y hago
lo mismo: 29 es mayor que 1, es mayor que 5, mayor
que 10, pero menor que 50, entonces está entre 10
y 50. ¿Cuántas decenas son? Son dos decenas, así
que voy a escribir XX, y ahora sé que he separado
esto, 29 lo he escrito como 20 + 9, y puedo
olvidarme del 20. Ahora tengo 9, y me pregunto
¿cómo escribo 9? No me tengo que preocupar de
lo que tenía antes, de eso todo lo que necesito
es preocuparme por cómo escribir el 9, y sé cómo
escribir 9: IX, así es como lo escribo, entonces
voy a escribir 9 como IX, y estoy escribiendo
esto separado para que puedas ver que se
escribe en notación sustractiva. Entonces,
¿cómo se lee este número? Será 50 + 20, que es
igual a 70, y cuando llegues aquí sabrás que
esto no es 21, pero si este número sólo llegara
hasta aquí, diríamos que el número es 50 + 20 + 1,
71. Sin embargo, cuando agrego esta X puedes ver
que es 1 - 10, y esto es 9, 79. Espero hayas usado
este mismo proceso mental o uno mejor tal vez. El
49 es muy interesante, quiero decirte que cuando
vi 49 estuve tentada a escribir IL, ¿por qué no?
Uno menos de 50. Resulta que no se hace así. Como
dijimos, sólo usamos notación sustractiva para
estos números, para 4, 9, 40, 90 o 400 o 900.
Entonces, ¿cómo planteamos este número? Puedo
tomar este número que es menor que 50, mayor que
10 y tiene cuatro decenas, lo que es 40; y aquí es
donde puede ponerse un poco confuso al principio:
¿cuánto es 40? Sé que 40 se escribe XL, entonces
escribo XL para 40 y luego sé que he escrito este
número como 40 + 9, y ya escribí la parte del 40,
podemos olvidarnos del 40 que es este XL. ¿Cómo es
el 9? Ya sé cómo escribir el 9, es: IX, así que
escribo IX justo aquí, entonces XLIX será 49.